[Music]
if you're pining over Peter Kavinsky
it's probably because you can't get over
how perfect he is well before you go
comparing your boyfriend to him let's
jump right into why this high school
stud was given us unrealistic
expectations about love watch until the
end to find out why Peter is too good to
be true new around here don't forget to
subscribe to the things and give us a
big thumbs up now let's dive right into
ten times Peter Kavinsky gave us
unrealistic expectations about love he
didn't tell anybody about the love
letter high school is a troubling time
for everyone even the jocks with this in
mind most students will go the extra
mile to get some attention it's no
secret that Peter Kavinsky
is a catch which is why he shouldn't
have been surprised to receive Laura
Jane's love letter most high schoolers
wouldn't miss the chance to tell the
entire school that someone loves them
instead of telling his friends about
Laura Jane's confession he decided to go
straight to the source Peter told Laura
Jean that he'd recently been dumped and
that it wasn't going to happen
Laura Jean who was clearly mortified
ended up kissing him to avoid having to
speak to Josh to say that this confused
Peter would be an understatement
once again Peter did the unexpected and
refrained from telling his friends
instead he went to Laura Jane's house to
make sure that they were on the same
page since most high schoolers wouldn't
think twice before posting Laura jeans
love letter online were led to think
that Peter might be too good to be true
after all he didn't tell a soul about
the embarrassing letter he wrote her
love notes after making a contract with
Laura Jean Peter stated that he would
write her love letters every single day
to piss off Jen of course the fact that
Peter actually did this is more than a
little confusing especially since he
actually filled up his notes with
genuine words flora Jean didn't even
bother reading his love notes because
she figured there'd be nothing inside of
them after all he didn't want to include
those notes in the contract to make his
ex jealous while there's plenty of guys
who would take the time to write their
girlfriends love notes during class to
expect this is sort of unrealistic the
difference between Jen and Laura Jean is
that Jim asked Peter to write her notes
while Laura Jean just let it happen
but we hate to say that daily love notes
are unreal is
dick we just can't help it after all
high schoolers tend to send each other
cute texts instead of taking the time to
write an adorable note or to want to
prove us wrong tell us about all the
love notes you've received in the
comments he was thinking long term if
there's one thing we all know too well
it's at high school relationships don't
always last regardless of this it's
better to have loved and lost than never
have loved it alright
when Peter Kavinsky approached Laura
Jean with his proposition he gave her
some time to think it over and to his
great surprise she accepted his offer
with the exception that some ground
rules be taken into account not having
the pressures of dating presence in the
relationship allowed both Peter and
Laura team to open up without being
afraid when the new couple sat down to
write out their contracts Peter insisted
that she accompanied him to the ski trip
however this event was three months away
the fact that Peter would date someone
for over three months to make his ex
jealous is super unrealistic but hey
Lara Jean wasn't complaining after all
being by his side stopped her from
feeling invisible are we the only ones
who think it's unrealistic for a boy to
get excited about taking his fake
girlfriend to a post-dated ski trip hmm
we don't think so he went to find her at
the corner cafe if there's one thing
high school boys don't usually do it's
show up at a girl's doorstep without
texting them first after telling Laura
Jean that he wasn't interested in her
that way Peter felt like he still needed
to clear the air after all Laura Jean
had practically jumped him after he
rejected her the youngest Kobe daughter
answered the door and told Peter where
he could find Laura Jean afterwards he
drove all the way to the corner cafe
ordered a milkshake and tried to talk
things over with the girl he thought to
be in love with while Peter's actions
were absolutely adorable we can't help
it address the elephant in the room why
wouldn't he just text her in this day
and age it's safe to say that a text
goes a long way which is why Peters
actions are more than unrealistic but
hey if any of you ever find someone
who's willing to show up in person to
discuss their feelings don't let them
get away
he watched sixteen Candles when Laura
Jean found out that Peter had never
watched the legendary movie Sixteen
Candles before she was at a loss for
words so much so that she requested the
you watch it with her as part of their
contract well it isn't
unrealistic to watch a movie with your
boyfriend be him of the fake variety or
not it is kind of unheard of for a high
school jock to watch a chick flick with
his girlfriend and her younger sister
not only did Peter enjoy spending the
nights with large eat and kitty but he
also made it a point to act out some of
its scenes with Lara Jean after all she
did want him to put his hand in her back
pocket as seen in the movie not only did
Peter respect her every wish but he also
made it a point to learn the hand and
pocket spin perfectly his new signature
move caused many viewers to wish that
their boyfriends would do the same now
we're not saying that it's impossible
for a man to watch a romantic comedy
with you and your family but we've only
ever seen this happen on the big screen
he drove across town to buy her yogurt
if there's one thing that everyone
deserves it's finding someone who will
go out of their way to make them happy
well we all find someone like this
eventually it can take time to truly
connect with another person on that
level Peter and Laura Jean quickly began
caring for one another however they had
a hard time being honest about how they
were feeling sure they could talk about
their family life and the many pressures
of adolescents but when it came to clear
in the air about their dating life
things got a little complicated
if there's one thing Laura Jean wasn't
looking forward to it was the ski trip
this is because she was starting to fall
for Peter and didn't want to complicate
things any further
Peter eventually convinced her to go by
getting her best friend to tag along the
fact that Peter wanted Lara Jean to come
on the ski trip that badly was
definitely adorable knowing that she
would be stepping out of her comfort
zone
Peter drove across town to buy some of
her favorite yogurts from a Korean
grocery store this kind and thoughtful
gesture might be sweet but it definitely
raises the bar for all the boys will
love in the future he showed her off to
the world relationships can go one or
two ways either they're amazing or they
drive you completely insane despite the
fact that Peter and Laura jeans
relationship was of the fake variety you
could say that they had an amazing
connection if there's one thing Peter
knows how to do its make Jen jealous
however after a few dates with Laura
Jean we sort of stopped believing that
his love for Jen was genuine
sure Peter might be showing Lara Jean
off to the world in order to piss his ex
off but there's something different
about the way he looks at her as soon as
Peter and Largey and make things
official he takes a picture of her and
puts it in his background on top of that
he also takes selfies with her and post
them on his social media accounts so in
other words he's truly showing her off
on every platform despite enjoying the
attention she's receiving Laura Jean can
help but keep her distance
after all she knows that the hammer will
drop sooner or later and that her
pictures will get replaced with ones of
Gen little does she know though that
Peter actually enjoys showing her off to
the world he was honest about how he
felt from very early on it becomes
obvious that Peters crushing on Laura
Jean for real unfortunately for them
they're both still convinced that what
they have is fake Peter is one who has
to set the pace during simple
conversations instead of flat out saying
that he likes her Peter tries to make
her see that his feelings are genuine
with his actions alone while on the ski
trip Peter and Lara Jean finally
confessed their feelings and make their
relationship real despite going to bed
on a high note the couple gets into a
spat the following morning when Jen
snakes her way between them when Peter
realizes that Laura Jean is avoiding his
calls he decides to show up to her house
he tries to come clean about how he
feels and tells her that she was never
second-best instead of getting into a
fight with Josh and ruining his chances
with large eeen Peter walks away and
leaves the rest of 8:00 but not before
telling Laura Jean how he really feels
about her he defended her in front of
the entire school Laura Jean never
wanted to go on the ski trip mainly
because she didn't know how to ski and
was afraid of getting intimate with
Peter despite not riding the bus with
Peter on the way there
Lara Jean sat next to him on the way
back however things got weird as soon as
she stepped onto the bus after all
everyone on it started clapping as
though she'd done something amazing
after getting into a spat with Peter
Laura Jane gets tagged in an Instagram
video by an unknown person this video
clearly shows her and Peter hooking up
in the hot tub not knowing what to do
Lara Jean turns to her big sister who
manages to take the video down fearing
that the worst is over Laura Jean
returns to school after the Christmas
break to find out that her locker has
been vandalized pictures of her in the
hot
Hubbard taped to her locker for all to
see instead of bragging about hooking up
with her
Peter yells at the entire school and
tells them that nothing happened on top
of that he tells its classmates that
whoever's caught talking about the
ordeal will have him to answer to if
only every high school boy was like
Peter the world would definitely be a
better place he respected all the rules
in the contract if there's one thing we
noticed while watching to all the boys
I've loved before
it's that Laura Jean didn't stay true to
the contract both she and Peter clearly
stated that none of them could tell
people that their relationship was fake
however Laura Jean told a few of her
friends about their little secret on the
other hand Peter never told a soul about
their arrangement which is totally hard
to believe that only did Peter respect
every single rule in the contract but he
also went above and beyond to court
Margene where we the only ones who kept
expecting the entire school to find out
about their fake relationship after all
our Jean did let the cat out of the bag
so this easily could have happened
luckily for her her friends Chris and
Lucas knew how to keep things
confidential so if Laura Jean went back
on her word and didn't tell Peter about
it who's to say that he didn't do the
same in the end we guess we'll have to
accept that Peter is perfect in every
way shape and form well he might seem
too good to be true
that won't stop any of us from having a
big fat crush on him so what's your
favorite Peter and Largey moment let us
know in the comments and that's a wrap
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]